des tribunes pleines à craquer près de
12000 personnes sont venues encourager
les meilleurs pilotes de bmx au stade
vélodrome de 50 ans c'est assez agréable
et entend de toute cette effervescence
c'est très beau ce qui plaît c'est de
voir tous ces pilotes qui sommes
vraiment très fort et qui roule vraiment
à un niveau très supérieur près de deux
cent soixante concurrents dont 100
français se sont affrontés pour les
cinquième et sixième manche de la coupe
du monde de la discipline
c'est chez nous c'est là puisqu'on
connaît le mieux donc toute la saison se
prépare dessus et c'est vraiment
l'événement le plus important pour nous
de cette saison
on a de plus en plus de pratiquants de
bmx ans dans notre pays et puis ensuite
sous l'angle de l'accompagnement vers le
haut niveau
le pôle olympique ici à saint quentin il
contribue beaucoup mais on a cette
capacité à s'installer de manière assez
permanente sur les podiums au niveau
international pari réussi pour les
français manon valentino a terminé
dimanche sur la plus haute marche du
podium
le public français était là à crier
encore et encore et je me suis dit faut
que j'aille pop geste et j'ai poussé
dans les vosges s'est passé c'est juste
incroyable de gagner ici
chez les hommes le français joris daudet
termine 3e samedi-- deuxième dimanche
les prochaines manches de la coupe du
monde se dérouleront les 14 et 15
septembre aux états unis